[Music]
but not everybody can win
two of the richest men in the world are
now officially in a space
race to make history but for sir richard
branson and jeff bezos there is a lot
more at stake here
than just bragging rights five four
command engines start two one
ignition three two one
release release release a ticket to
space is becoming
far less out of this world just ask
these two billionaires
this july our dream will become a
reality
it's time to go back to the moon this
time to stay two of the richest men on
the planet
are cleared for liftoff astronaut 001
richard branson beginning the revolution
for space tourism
virgin galactic founder and billionaire
richard branson stole
a little of fellow billionaire jeff
bezos's thunder yesterday when he
announced he will be launching himself
into space
two when we return i will announce
something
very exciting to give more people the
chance to become
astronauts because space does belong to
us
all branson will join five other people
on a round trip from new mexico to
somewhere above the earth next week
beating bezos's space company's
inaugural human flight by
nine days point to branson this
is the beginning of a revolution in
space travel and blue origin
is going to take you there but remember
bezos has made his starry flight
a family affair brother mark will
accompany jeff on july 20th
point to bezos because that's kind of
sweet
it's one small step for man
the competition to be the first to take
a leap like this
is part of a larger competition to
attract detention and
tourists both billionaires companies
plan to offer
short rides for the wealthy who want to
float amongst the stars
they'll also both offer trips to
researchers neither company has been
totally clear about how
much each ride will cost but a still
anonymous bidder grabbed a seat on board
the blue origin flight for 28 million
dollars at auction
600 people prepaid up to a quarter
million dollars each for a seat on
virgin when it begins commercial
operations in 2022
giving branson a little edge with an
extra 150 million dollars
we're going to fly you up into space on
the very first flight
that's your is also winning the
heartstrings race
yesterday he announced 82 year old wally
funk would be on his spaceship
she's been waiting half a century to go
to space she trained for nasa's mercury
program in 1961
but was denied the opportunity until now
i can hardly wait fulfilling a dream
that could become reality
for so many more wow
so tony is it a game of who's is bigger
i i'm not answering that question i
would answer it i would answer tony you
can answer i would answer in the
in the affirmative yeah uh and i think
in terms of
i said go ahead tony you would answer in
the affirmative in the affirmative
and i'll say it's going to be very
exciting to see what the ultimate answer
is but it does seem to be a coincidence
that
jeff bezos announces and now richard
branson announces do they both have to
go in july right
that's all i'm saying you know there is
a first mover advantage that they both
recognize from their skills in business
well it's fun it's fun to watch i will
say that and i think they're both i
think they're both terrific
it'll be interesting to see how it turns
out that wally funk i love the
exchange between jeff bezos and wally
funk at 82
that she gets to do whatever you want to
do yeah i'm so thrilled i would be that
thrilled as well i'm actually rooting
for both of them because i hope it
becomes normal that we go up there
well i'll sit here and cheer you on i'm
rooting for both of them i am too
i am too billionaire's on the rise there
you go